en tant qu'une trop exposé à la
télévision il ya de plus en plus des
missions et des enfants maintenant et ça
cartonne ya 5000 nombreux sur tf1 depuis
cinq saisons il ya maman est célèbre et
donc à une fille une femme qui s'est
fait connaître dans l'émission famille
nombreuse de l'avion xxl c'est amandine
pélissard c'est d'une personne de
notoriété publique regardez à la 8
enfants et regardant l'émission s'était
mis la table à ce qu'a dit ce n'est pas
moi qui me lot
[Musique]
c'est un bonheur ne peut pas se lasser
de donner le
temps de comprendre des angles droits
les
normes à
ses jours c'est mon saison
du temps chaud protestation à l'infini
d'aplats aucune
voilà et amandine pélissard depuis cinq
saisons dans l'émission nous a rejoints
maman de huit enfants et plus bien sûr
un compte instagram bien bien fourni il
ya une de vos filles de vos huit enfants
qu'il a dans les loges mais conviennent
tout à l'heure parce qu'on va d'abord
exposé des jeux dire des choses un petit
peu enfin voilà plus plutôt cheap et
donc faut pas qu'elles entendent tout ça
et c'est vrai que voilà vous avez 35 ans
vous avez huit enfants qui vont de quel
âge à calage à peu près bientôt 16 ans à
deux ans l'accord de deux ans à 16 ans
voilà donc ils sont très exposés puisque
ce sont tf1 voilà et ben vous avez été
un petit peu les frais de tout ça parce
que ya pas très longtemps vous avez reçu
quatre jusqu'à quatre lettres de menaces
de mort c'est ça et on va dire peut-être
la première parce que c'est elle
concerne vos enfants donc c'est la plus
violente bah pardon je dis tout ça vous
dérange pas espèce de saloperies avec ta
gueule botoxée tu ressens vraiment à ce
que tu es une arabe avec tes cheveux
frisés girondine à ce que je lis enfin
là l'usiné on craint des familles
nombreuses sont les eaux donc c'est
votre fils aîné et sa gueule d'arabe
vraiment j'ai honte de ce que je lis
avec sa choucroute sur la tête alex
complètement conne l'ena petite [ __ ]
malpolis insolente vous comprenez
maintenant pourquoi maintenant la saison
fort de pamiers c'est qu'une bête sur
les quatre on n'ira pas sur les 4 vous
avez porté plainte évidemment à la
police pour l'instant c'est en cours
mais se passe pas grand chose ne peut
pas leur en vouloir il faut essayer de
trouver
d'abord à votre avis pourquoi pourquoi
vous êtes nombreux il ya jusqu'à huit
familles par par émission ulysse
pourquoi pourquoi vous qu'est ce qui
s'est passé pourquoi vous avez généré ça
de saison en saison il y avait meilleur
même jusqu'à 15 16 familles sur elles
sont complètement
je sais pas pourquoi alors après serait
que nous on est là enfin je veux pas
dire qu'on est à la famille qui était le
plus critiqué depuis le début mais je
pense qu'on en a quand même pris plus
que les zones et pourquoi ben je sais
pas alors on est là depuis la première
saison c'est vrai qu'on a un profil un
peu atypique qui peut déranger on a
revendiqué être parent foyer à ceux à
cette époque là par choix à la naissance
de notre sixième enfant on a fait ce
choix de se dévouer à nos enfants et de
travailler depuis notre domicile ça a
beaucoup déplu parce qu'on est dans des
clichés toute façon sur les familles
nombreuses qui sont qu'est ce que je
peux vous couper la forêt c'est d'abord
dire qu'effectivement ces lettres de
menaces sont arrivés dans votre boîte
aux lettres un nom sur instagram
est ce qui a énervé aussi c'est
peut-être pas le fait que avant de faire
cette émission vous n'aviez pas beaucoup
de revenus en exposant ses enfants dans
cette émission maintenant paraît-il que
vous avez des gros revenus avec grâce
aux réseaux sociaux jeudi à 34 euros par
mois et ce qui agace les gens c'est que
vous avez finalement l'évolution est là
si vous avez instrumentalisé vos enfants
pour de google et de l'argent alors vous
aviez tartaglia maison des chats c'est
la question que je crois que je passe à
kathak les gens quelqu'un déjà encore
une fois nous on est là depuis la saison
1 oui cette émission nous l'a proposé
elle est d elle existait pas un petit
coup avant j'étais vendeuse donc vous
gagnez pas quarante mille euros avant ah
non mais je gagne pas car en paix leur
aujourd'hui non plus ah bon c'est ce que
j'ai entendu à voyager plus vous gagnez
vous faire et par mois on combien trois
mois par mois voilà ici 1400 euros par
mois ben c'est à dire moi ici au srd
zodiac estime que rien mais après on
s'en fout peu importe
c'est pas méchant ce que j'ai c'était
brésil comprendre mes yeux tu sais pas
vraiment d un premier renvoi était à
bord et oui compte épargne à remplir
pour leur majorité donc faire lors de
combien je gagne aux médias que c'est
pas une bombe de gagner de l'argent il
n'y a pas de problème mais je dirai pas
combien non mais en tout cas plus que
quand vous étiez vendeuse oui évidemment
non mais c'est pas un reproche c'est
pour essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est
passé est ce que peut-être les gens
peuvent vous reprocher parce que non
mais oui du mal à comprendre pourquoi on
s'attaque à vous comme ça le coton et
violence mais après c'est aussi le
prochain enfin je pense qu'on a on a un
profil si on est là depuis la saison 1
c'est peut-être aussi parce que sans
doute on a un profil particulier savait
qu'on avait un caractère spécial comment
je le sais mon mari il est aux antipodes
de moi donc on est vraiment et je pense
que ça fait un truc que les gens pètent
enfin je sais pas ça les fait il y en a
eu des sk ok moi vous êtes dis leur que
vous n'avez aucun enfant qui est majeure
donc vous avez pris des décisions pour
eux aucun moment vous vous êtes dit à
l'école les répercussions je suis en
train de les rendre célèbres et vont
peut-être on en connaît des enfants
comme a vécu la célébrité des genres dit
à aucun moment vous avez des questions à
chaque saison et à chaque même chaque
soir avec mes enfants on en parle alors
encore je reviens ce que je disais en
saison 1 on nous a proposé cette
émission elle n'existait pas ouais ça ne
veut pas être sur tf1 c'était un
documentaire nous c'était vraiment un
partage au départ quotidien personnes
savaient que ce sera un succès personne
savait que ça allait durer personne ne
le présageait en tout cas aujourd'hui
faut quand même savoir qu'aujourd'hui il
ya des vrais travers il ya des familles
où il ya des moments qui met cube sur
instagram qui me disent oh là là bas là
je sais que c'est le sixième enfant pour
pouvoir passer le casting je veux dire
cela en fait les familles aujourd'hui il
y en a qui passent au casting dans le
but qu'ils pensent qu'ils se disent en
vous voyant que si on a des enfants et
qu'on les exposants gagnera de l'argent
mais il y en a qui se dit çà dans les
tracés des sites urbains exemple vous ne
gagnez pas mal mais non mais je veux
dire c'est des vrais travers où il se
compose ça c'est des vrais travers mes
enfants à chaque fois on les a consultés
avant d'ailleurs on me reproche souvent
comment consulte un enfant de 5 6 ans
amandine comme on lui demande pas
justement un truc tout simple
5-6 ans est tout à fait l'âge de mon
fils a dont j'allais parler on me dit
mais lui on le voit pas il est deux
côtés machin non en fait c'est que nos
enfants les agendas on les a jamais
obligé à tourner quoi que ce soit s'ils
ont pas envie il tourne pas quant à une
caméra chez nous s'ils ont pas envie
d'étudier mais ils ne sont pas filmés ça
ne les entraves jamais leur l'école n'a
aucun souci aucun souci n'y a pas de
harcèlement à l'école moi c'est ce que
je dis les gamins sont plus intelligents
que les adultes parce que c'est le plus
tôt les parents ont fait un qui nous
enquiquine à la sortie de l'école les
gamins fin il n'y a jamais eu en tout
cas dans ma famille pour mes enfants il
n'y a jamais eu aucun souci d'accord
c'est le nom scolaire alors moi je veux
leur parce que là aujourd'hui n'ont
peut-être pas encore conscience de
l'impact possible de cette médiatisation
et peut-être que dans quelques années
peut-être qu'à 18 ans ils vont vous
reprocher et peut-être même vous en
vouloir à la terre il y avait déjà pensé
mais bien sûr mais je pense qu'à 18 ans
moi distance j'ai raccroché plein de
trucs à ma mère elle m'a jamais mise à
la télé enfin briller sur les boucles
soit alors laurent tu voulais poser une
question dont on sait pas de question
j'ai juste parce que moi j'ai twitté les
enfants voilà j'ai eu dix enfants bien
sûr mais chez sur lookbook pur produit
beaucoup d'émissions et la vérité qui
compte où il y avait des gens qui
venaient exposer leur vie privée donc se
posait cette question là le problème
c'est que des familles on reviendra
toujours eu la télé c'est vrai mais pour
l'épreuve de télé on adore les familles
nombreuses les voir faire c'est
maintenant en 2022 à cause des réseaux
sociaux qu'on a quatre un agresseur la
sq en réalité il ya des millions de
personnes qui regardent et qui vous
adore donc on est en train de monter en
épingle 3 connard raciste qui s'exprime
en réalité voilà avant alors oui non
laurent moi j'ai vu et je ne dis pas
pour amandine je sais pas mais moi j'ai
vu aussi des influences aujourd'hui sur
les réseaux sociaux posés avec un bébé
qui a déjà une marque à
travers ça c'est d'être un fait d'être
amère chose que je ne serai jamais et
baisser et je n'entends alors vu que
l'on parle de travers c'est important ce
que je veux dire j'ai vu dans un
interview vous avez dit vous reprocher à
une autre famille de vous plagié le mot
le mot fin mai le mot plagiat est quand
même pas anodin c'est ça veut dire qu'il
ya une sorte une certaine mise en scène
est ce que vous mettez en scène
finalement votre vie de famille enfin
les deux ça ça sera le mot plagiat il a
du temps il n'est pas choisi par hasard
là je parlais de sa part dans le rapport
aux réseaux sociaux sur un stade homme
je parlais pas dans l'émission alors oui
alors ludivine quand même la petite
ludivine six mamans aussi amandine et
moi j'ai aucune aucune leçon est
maintenant temps sur le réseau je n'ai
pas de cette façon en fait je pourrais
je pourrais pas et certainement pas
appelé mais quand même été connus j ouer
j'aimais chez connu mais pas lors
monfils très peu ma fille qui a 18 ans
et donc qui s'assume et kiev son compte
instagram ok moi j'ai deux questions à
vous poser la toute première c'est
quelles sont les limites que vous vous
imposez avec votre famille est ce que
vous avez des limites à ne pas dépasser
et surtout avec toutes ces menaces et
même s'il faut pas répondre aux
agresseurs il faut faut jamais voilà
seul et c'est peut-être un petit peu
influencé et ou terrorisés est ce que ça
ne vous motive pas arrêté à ce genre de
menaces centrale en or au contraire mais
non jamais jamais je ne m'abaisserai je
ne bougeais devant mes détracteurs mais
jamais la vie non j'entends bien entendu
fait ce serait cautionner l' or
seulement moi je suis pour la loi je
peine à l'encontre des enfants à la télé
on envoie depuis des années depuis des
décennies ce qui est nouveau c'est de se
faire déglinguer comme ça sur la rosa
mais alors là alors alors il les menace
de mort on est d'accord que c'est une
honte c'est une annonce est vraiment
table la thur et complètement de votre
côté et c'est vrai qu'encore une fois on
ne juge pas on se pose des questions des
questions qu'on se pose est peut-être
que j'aurais fait pareil à votre place
si j'avais été vendeur et que tout d'un
coup bas la télévision m'amène plus
d'argent et plus d'exposition mais c'est
vrai qu'on a le droit de se poser des
questions quand vous dites je les laisse
choisir un enfant de 5 6 ans et choisit
pas si sa maman lui dit pas devant la
caméra il valait fera que non parce que
non mais mais mais absolument pas mais
enfin mon fils adam k 6 ans quand il a
pas envie il ne fit non mais non alors
me rées jamais de la vie je n'ai rien
armand déjà pas très calé en enfance
jour là on est peut-être quelque part
mes jeunes ignorent alors la question
c'était vraiment par rapport à là je
sais qu'à un moment vous avez vous aviez
dit on attend qu'il se passe quoi on va
attendre que mon fils se prennent un
coup de couteau au coin de la rue en
allant prendre le bus donc ma question
vraiment c'est justement je vous
retourne cette question est ce que vous
attendez qu'un drame pareil abonnés
sueur qui n'arrivera pas arrive pour
arrêter les réseaux sociaux ou pour
arrêter d'exciter un peu les haters
parce que pour arrêter l'effusion
constituera également arrêté l'émission
clair noir sur excellente question
deborah non moi ce que j'attends alors
j'ai utilisé cette phrase forte
justement voilà parce que ce qui me
dérange beaucoup c'est que j'en suis à
ma deuxième plainte j'ai déposé plainte
deux fois j'ai l'impression qu'ils se
passe pas grand chose mais on fait la
police pour les choses un peu de façon
légère 1 quand je vais déposer ma
première plainte que le policier me dit
pouvait prendre un garde du corps enfin
on sent quand même quelle légèreté et
vous avez pensé ça avec l'argent que
vous gagnez maintenant apprendre et
butane et les services de sécurité en
passant je veux pas long parce que je
veux pas je ne veux pas partir dans une
paranoïa non je suis normalement en fait
oui mais ses membres et de ses seuls et
que vous aviez part pour votre sécurité
et vous dites moi je ne veux pas arrêter
parce que ces données leur leur donner
raison je peux comprendre mais là étant
donné qu'il ya eu huit petites personnes
qui sont inclus dans ce truc là oui
est-ce que c'est pas un peu entre
guillemets égoïstes nous en dire mais
pas du tout nos enfants les protègent
nos enfants y sont pas libres à eux ben
oui mais bon les fours et si nous les
matins pour aller prendre son peut rien
contre les cinglés mal exactement ça que
mon fils y ait dans un taxi tous les
mamans dean dans un avion on dirait on
posera livre à votre fille qui était
avec nous après je rappelle qu'on aura
pierre jean charles tanguay sera avec
nous et puis un gros dossier sur deux
nil est ce bien la main en l'air pendant
ses amis commencent à une belle
transition ça va moins bien tu me tues
me connaissait ah oui
[Musique]
en effet
voilà avec un monsieur pasqua nîmes à
côté de moi qu'à elle cyril le trop
gentil cyril animateurs tmp
l'argentine
c'est vrai c'est vrai et aime beaucoup
aussi
quel âge as tu
sais pas tant de moi je répondrai nom de
mme ouattara dix ans alors moi dans neuf
mois j'aurai dans deux mois par exemple
celle des grands maintenant à 25 ans
nancy limoges absolument alors on parler
de l'émission était dans l'émission
depuis plusieurs saisons sur tf1
est ce que tu es à l'aise dans
l'émission que tu es content d'y être
oui était à l'école dans quelle classe
schirrhein scène chaque matin vous le
sort de ce corps sexy
pour connaître son corps découpé un
enfant pourrait avoir débité
au rose à l'école il ya aucun tester tes
amis te se moque pas de toi parce que tu
es dans l'émission pas du tout ni les
profs moi ça m'arrange lise oui non
personne rien on va bien les maris et
heureuse ah le bonheur ça fait pas venir
vendre il faut que tu me racontes
institut voix on a été très très bien et
tes frères et soeur ils sont heureux
d'être dans l'émission bah oui pense
hélas aucun qui se plaint non non non
vous êtes très heureuse la très jolie
était heureuse
donc tout va bien oui elle va très bien
alors tu sais quoi pas aussi un gros
bisou à ryad une dernière question de
d'isabelle c'est autant souviens parce
que c'était avant d'accueillir et la lie
à tous qui remonte rewind rewind
simplement en toute honnêteté ce que
vous n'êtes pas le sentiment vous êtes
laissés prendre au jeu que vous voulez
absolument pas relancer cette émission
parce que la première saison pensait pas
que ça durerait aussi longtemps non et
maintenant donc c'était devenu un outre
un vrai boulot et vagues à la
médiatisation au quat'sous
indépendamment des choses désagréables
et à la fascination quand même d'être au
coeur de quelque chose serait pas le
sentiment que vous montez vous même de
temps en temps quand vous dites que moi
lorsque j'ai dit c'est que je ne serai
pas cette émission pour cette raison là
après je peux être amené à arrêter de
tourner les familles nombreuses pour x
ou y raison mais un cerveau tf1 qui vous
arrêtera vont vous arrêter on sent le
pro
le pro des licenciements auraient pas le
choix vous avant de se quitter est ce
que les a
jugés délai non non c'est divenach
nantais dilena
je sais bien lna est-ce que tu as que tu
aimerais que la chaîne ces huit mètres
un petit peu plus en avant matthieu
delormeau en tant qu'animateur sur des
prime time
est ce que c'est parce que tu sais
qu'ils écoutent beaucoup les enfants tu
aimerais ça c'est rien compris
à la merci merci beaucoup on peut les
raccompagner merci beaucoup
merci
vraiment tout coeur voir
matthieu delormeau séville
19h10 à gassiès